Wir haben heute einen ziemlich
interessanten Tag für KI-Nachrichten,
denn wir haben einige neue Erkenntnisse
zu Anthropics neuem Modell, Claude Opus
5.2, das anscheinend schon bald
erscheinen wird. Es wird erwartet, dass
dies Fähigkeiten auf Fabel-Niveau in
die Opus-Familie bringt, was bedeutet,
dass es wahrscheinlich extrem teuer
sein wird, aber möglicherweise eines
der leistungsfähigsten Modelle von
Anthropic bisher ist. Aber Anthropic
ist nicht das einzige Unternehmen, das
etwas plant, denn OpenAI scheint
ebenfalls bereit zu sein, mit GPT-6 die
nächste Modellgeneration auf den Markt
zu bringen, wobei Soul und Luna Teil
dieser Modellreihe sein werden. Wir
sind uns noch nicht sicher, was es mit
Hera als Teil von GPT-6 auf sich hat,
aber wir haben endlich erste Vorschauen
auf diese Modelle erhalten, und die
Ergebnisse sind momentan ziemlich wild.
Obwohl Soul im Vergleich zu Astra als
Modell leicht verkleinert zu sein
scheint, liefert es bereits Ergebnisse,
die überraschend nah an die Leistung
von Asher heranreichen, und das alles
zu deutlich geringeren Kosten. Und die
Dinge werden noch seltsamer, denn
gestern haben wir darüber gesprochen,
wie Anthropic-CEO Dario Amodei dazu
aufrief, den Prozess der KI-Entwicklung
zu verlangsamen. Und das hat plötzlich
dazu geführt, dass andere KI-Größen
wie Elon Musk sowie Sam Altman die Idee
zu unterstützen schienen, die
Entwicklung von Spitzen-KI-Modellen zu
bremsen. Warum sprechen so viele
führende KI-Köpfe zur gleichen Zeit
darüber? Man fragt sich, ob sie intern
etwas gesehen haben? Haben sie die AGI
erreicht? Haben sie tatsächlich etwas
getan, das der Gesellschaft schaden
könnte? Wir haben natürlich keine
Ahnung, aber das Timing ist definitiv
interessant. Dann schaltete sich Donald
Trump in die Unterhaltung ein, lehnte
die Idee ab, dass die KI-Entwicklung
verlangsamt werden sollte, und
argumentierte, dass die Vereinigten
Staaten weiterhin auf dieses neue
KI-Tempo drängen sollten, was uns
wahrscheinlich innerhalb weniger Jahre
in die AGI-Diskussionen führen würde.
Also hat sich die KI-Skalierung
irgendwie zu einer noch größeren
politischen Debatte entwickelt.
Unterdessen arbeitet DeepSeek Berichten
zufolge an DeepSeek Coder 2.0, bei dem
es sich Gerüchten zufolge um ein
massives Coding-Modell mit 3 Billionen
Parametern und offenen Gewichten
handelt. Das Ziel scheint zu sein, die
Fähigkeiten auf Spitzen-Niveau
vollständig darauf auszurichten, mit
GPT-Coding-Modellen gleichzuziehen und
gleichzeitig die Gewichte offen zu
halten, was eine enorme Leistung für
die Serie sowie für das Unternehmen
selbst wäre. Nun gibt es natürlich
noch viel mehr zu besprechen, also
tauchen wir einfach direkt in alles ein
. Es gibt eine Menge Dinge im
KI-Bereich, die ich nicht wirklich auf
den YouTube-Kanal bringe, und auf die
Sie über meinen kostenlosen Newsletter
zugreifen können–den Link dazu
finden Sie unten in der Beschreibung,
wo Sie sich völlig kostenlos anmelden
können. Beginnen wir mit Claude Opus
5.2, denn dieses Modell wurde
anscheinend bei Anthropic gesichtet,
was darauf hindeutet, dass ein
größeres Claude-Upgrade näher rückt
. Es gibt zwar noch sehr wenige
Informationen über Claude Opus 5.2,
daher sollte man diese Leaks mit
Vorsicht genießen, aber wir wissen,
dass dieses Modell intern gesehen wurde
, was bedeutet, dass Anthropic kurz vor
der Veröffentlichung steht. Opus wird
definitiv ein riesiges Upgrade,
besonders mit der 5.2-Version, aber man
fragt sich, warum sie die 5.1
eigentlich übersprungen haben. Ich bin
mir nicht sicher warum, aber dieses
Opus-Upgrade wäre ziemlich interessant
, da Opus 5 bereits darauf ausgelegt
war, der Intelligenz von Fable
erstaunlich nahezukommen und dabei
deutlich günstiger zu sein. Die große
Frage ist also, wie weit Anthropic mit
Opus 5.2 gehen will. Da Stable 5.1 und
Mythos 5.1 die Entwicklung von
Anthropic bereits vorantreiben, könnte
ein verbessertes Opus-Modell einige
dieser Verbesserungen erben,
insbesondere bei Coding-Agenten,
langfristigen Aufgaben sowie logischem
Denken. Letzteres ist vorerst
Spekulation, aber wenn Anthropic mehr
seiner Spitzenfähigkeiten in die
Opus-Familie einbringen kann, könnte
Opus 5.2 eines der praktischen Modelle
werden, die man täglich nutzen möchte
. Und wenn sie das Preisproblem bei
diesem Opus-Modell lösen können,
würde das die Sicht vieler Leute auf
die Modelle von Anthropic definitiv
verändern. Aber das ist nicht das
Einzige, das bald erscheinen könnte,
denn OpenAI scheint sich auch auf die
Veröffentlichung von GPT-6 Soul und
Luna vorzubereiten. Wir sehen nun die
ersten Vorab-Einblicke darauf, was GPT-
6 Soul tatsächlich leisten kann. Ich
vermute, dass sie es möglicherweise am
Dev Day veröffentlichen werden, der
später in diesem Monat stattfindet.
Das wäre definitiv ein riesiges
Upgrade und ein neues Modell, das sie
veröffentlichen würden–im Grunde
eine kosteneffiziente Version von Astra
. Eines der verrücktesten Beispiele
bisher ist die Erstellung des
Todessterns, wobei GPT-6 Soul die
Aufgabe erhielt, in einer
vollständigen Simulation des
Todessterns aus Star Wars mit maximalem
logischem Aufwand im
Zero-Shot-Verfahren zu arbeiten. Das
Modell arbeitete etwa 9 Minuten lang
daran und generierte rund 72.000 Token,
was für einen einzigen Versuch
natürlich eine wahnsinnige Menge an
Output ist. Was dies besonders
interessant macht, ist, dass Soul nicht
als das absolute High-End-Modell von
OpenAI gedacht ist. Das ist etwas, das
Astra übertreffen wird. Dies ist eine
Stufe unter Astra, die versucht, dessen
Fähigkeiten zu imitieren, dabei aber
offensichtlich weitaus effizienter und
kostengünstiger ist. Wenn wir also
eine bessere Preisstruktur für dieses
Modell bekommen, wäre es
offensichtlich ein großartiges Modell
für den täglichen Gebrauch, das man
möglicherweise jeden Tag nutzen
könnte. Aber sie arbeiten auch an der
Veröffentlichung des GPT-6
Luna-Modells, das als kosteneffizientes
Modell Teil der GPT-6-Familie sein soll
. Hier ist eine weitere Demo des GPT-6
Soul-Modells. Die Programmierung und
die Frontend-Arbeit sind definitiv
beeindruckend, besonders wenn man
bedenkt, dass dies das günstigere GPT-
6-Modell sein soll, das unterhalb von
Astra angesiedelt ist. Und genau das
könnte Soul so bedeutend machen, denn
wenn die ersten Preisberichte stimmen,
könnten wir potenziell
Programmierfähigkeiten auf
Astra-Niveau zu deutlich geringeren
Kosten erhalten. Wir wissen, dass das
Astra-Modell recht teuer ist. Wenn wir
also eine reduzierte Preisstruktur für
das Soul-Modell aus derselben Familie
bekommen, wäre es für alltägliche
Programmieraufgaben und agentische
Workflows deutlich praktischer. Als
Nächstes haben wir Dario Amodei, den
CEO von Anthropic, über den wir
gestern bereits berichtet haben,
nachdem er einen neuen Artikel
veröffentlichte, in dem er über das
Tempo an der KI-Front diskutiert. Der
Zeitpunkt ist ziemlich interessant,
denn obwohl Dario davor warnt, wie
schnell sich die KI-Entwicklung
beschleunigt, gibt es keine
öffentlichen Anzeichen dafür, dass
Anthropic selbst die Entwicklung seiner
kommenden Spitzenmodelle pausiert. Wie
wir gerade besprochen haben,
konzentrieren sie sich auf Opus 5.2 und
auf ein neues Modell, das nach der
Fable-oder Mythos-Serie kommen wird.
Der wichtigere Punkt, den Dario
anspricht, ist jedoch, wohin das alles
letztendlich führen wird. Er glaubt,
dass wir an einen Punkt kommen, an dem
KI-Systeme selbst maßgeblich an der
Entwicklung der nächsten KI-Generation
beteiligt sind. Er sagt in seinem
Artikel ausdrücklich, dass sich der
KI-Fortschritt seit etwa diesem Sommer
drastisch beschleunigt hat. Und das
haben Sie ja auch gesehen. Ich habe
ständig vom KI-Sommer gesprochen. Wir
haben so viele neue Modelle gesehen.
Ich bin momentan unterwegs und habe
Schwierigkeiten, diese
Modell-Review-Videos zu produzieren.
Und man merkt deutlich, dass die
Videoqualität nicht mit dem
vergleichbar ist, was wir vor meiner
Reise hatten. Trotzdem mache ich so
viele KI-Review-Videos, und es ist
einfach verrückt, weil wir jeden
zweiten Tag ein neues Modell bekommen.
Und genau das treibt die KI-Entwicklung
bei Anthropic maßgeblich voran.
Natürlich wird es dabei helfen, neue
Nachfolger und KI-Modelle zu bauen,
aber es beschleunigt definitiv das
Rennen an der KI-Front rasant. Und
sobald Modelle maßgeblich an der
Entwicklung zukünftiger Modelle
beteiligt sind, argumentiert Dario im
Grunde, dass die Verbesserungsrate
atemberaubend schnell werden könnte.
Dies ist im Wesentlichen die Idee
hinter rekursiver Selbstverbesserung
oder RSI. Da KI zunehmend bei der
KI-Forschung hilft, entstehen
offensichtlich bessere KI-Systeme, was
den Forschungsprozess noch weiter
beschleunigen kann. Dario erwähnte
daraufhin einige ziemlich extreme
potenzielle Risiken durch RSI, was bei
vielen Leuten für Angst sorgte. Denn
wenn wir diesen Punkt erreichen,
könnte dies im Grunde zu vielen
Cyberangriffen führen; eine Menge
schädlicher Dinge könnten aufgrund
von KI-Anwendungsfällen und anderen
Faktoren entstehen. Und kurz nachdem
Dario diese Aussage gemacht hatte,
schienen Elon Musk und Sam Altman
plötzlich eine Verlangsamung des
KI-Wettlaufs zu unterstützen, was
einen fragen lässt, was sie eigentlich
erschreckt hat, da sie alle aus dem
Nichts dasselbe sagten. Es gibt
natürlich eine ganze Reihe von
Möglichkeiten. Vielleicht sehen diese
Labore intern Fähigkeiten, die weitaus
näher an AGI liegen als das, was wir
öffentlich gesehen haben. Oder ganz im
Gegenteil: Vielleicht befürchten die
führenden Labore, dass ihre
Wettbewerbsvorteile schwinden, und eine
allgemeine Verlangsamung hilft, ihre
Position und Bewertung zu schützen.
Das ist natürlich alles Spekulation,
aber das Timing der aktuellen
Ereignisse lässt einen schon grübeln.
Und das Lustige ist, dass Donald Trump,
der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten,
praktisch aus dem Nichts auftauchte und
sich zufällig in dieses Gespräch
einmischte, um sich gegen die Idee
einer Verlangsamung der KI-Entwicklung
zu wehren. Seine Position ist im Grunde
das Gegenteil: Amerika sollte nicht vom
Gas gehen, besonders während es mit
Ländern wie China im Bereich KI
konkurriert. Wir haben also einige der
größten Namen der KI-Branche, die
plötzlich davon sprechen, den
Fortschritt zu verlangsamen. Hier sagt
Trump im Grunde das Gegenteil und meint
, dass sie einfach weitermachen sollten
. Es ist auf jeden Fall wirklich
interessant und amüsant. Wenn dir
dieses Video gefällt und du den Kanal
unterstützen möchtest, kannst du eine
Spende über die „Super Thanks“-
Option unten in Betracht ziehen. Oder
du trittst unserem privaten Discord bei
, wo du monatlich kostenlosen Zugriff
auf verschiedene KI-Tools sowie
tägliche KI-Nachrichten, exklusive
Inhalte und mehr erhältst. Zuletzt
gibt es einige ziemlich massive neue
Updates von DeepSeek mit DeepSeek Code
2.0. Dies ist ein Modell, dessen
Veröffentlichung für September
geplant ist, und Gerüchten zufolge
könnte es ein Modell mit über 3
Billionen Parametern und einem 1-
Million-Token-Kontextfenster sein, das
zudem Open-Weight bleibt. Sie verfügen
außerdem über
Computer-Nutzungsfähigkeiten, und der
Fokus liegt diesmal angeblich auf
Effizienz sowie der Fähigkeit, den
Bildschirm präzise zu steuern. Die
verrückteste Behauptung ist, dass
DeepSeek anscheinend Leistungen
anstrebt, die mit den besten Modellen
wie Fable oder sogar GPT konkurrieren
oder diese grundlegend übertreffen
könnten. Natürlich sollte man das mit
Vorsicht genießen, da ich glaube, dass
das nur Hype ist, aber letztendlich
wäre dies ein wirklich cooles Modell
aus China von DeepSeek, das mit dem
aktuellen Stand der Technik
konkurrieren würde. Aber das war es
auch schon, Leute, mit allem, was in
der Welt der KI passiert. Falls ihr es
noch nicht getan habt, schaut euch
unbedingt die Welt der KI in der School
Community an, wo ihr Zugang zu
Vorab-Modellen sowie kostenlosen Zugang
zu KI-Tools erhaltet. Werft unbedingt
einen Blick auf die Welt der KI-5-
Coding-Plattform und das Benchmark.
Schaut euch den zweiten Kanal an.
Stellt außerdem sicher, dass ihr euch
für den Newsletter anmeldet. Tretet
unserem Discord bei. Folgt mir auf
Twitter. Und zu guter Letzt: Abonniert
den Kanal, aktiviert die
Benachrichtigungsglocke, liked dieses
Video und schaut euch unsere früheren
Videos an, damit ihr bei den neuesten
KI-Nachrichten auf dem Laufenden bleibt
. Aber mit diesem Gedanken, Leute, habt
einen fantastischen Tag. Wir sind
durchweg positiv, und ich sehe euch
sehr bald wieder. Macht's gut, Leute.